[Musique]
pas
c'est un grand moment pour ces élèves de
primaire et du collège henri matisse de
bois d'olives une dernière répétition
sur scène des deux chansons de daniel
waro qu'ils vont interpréter en duo et
en live au théâtre de saint-gilles
on doit apprendre la langue créole en
fait parce que ça s'est dégradé
je pourrais apprend comment ça se disait
avoir les carreaux de bois ça veut dire
dans les bois je crois et après est vrai
aussi que ça veut dire
les bains les bains fidh dans les champs
c'est une rencontre improbable sans
vainqueur qui accompagne danyel waro sur
scène une collaboration de plusieurs
mois de travail partagé le temps d'un
concert
[Musique]
la bataille pour la bouffe les notes au
bac pro pas trop parents et nounous
territoire pas gagné un but nous mêmes
jean pierre est mon but est là jordi bon
soit-il ganis a été un plaisir du
théâtre dans l'école
partout j'ai adoré c'était sympa le
spectacle je me suis amusé j'ai pas
trouvé mme pagé voit maintenant mais si
je me suis vraiment amusé c'est ça qui
compte et fiat richesse va pas bien
travaillé depuis la rentrée de septembre
tous les midis les nazis me disant
l'atelier avec moins d'un ultime ensuite
rapidement et enchaîner épreuve en cours
après l'après midi un concert qui marque
l'un des moments forts des célébrations
des 50 ans du théâtre de saint gilles
pendant toute cette année la
programmation musicale plus particulière
fera place à la fête et à l'ambiance
unique des concerts en plein air
[Musique]